Janine für viele Israelis die Hauptstadt
des Terrors für viele Palästinenser die
Hauptstadt des Widerstands zwei Tage
tobte im Flüchtlingslager dort der
Häuserkampf vor allem Straßen sind
zerstört
israelische Bulldozer haben sie
systematisch aufgerissen auf der Suche
nach Sprengfallen was im Weg war wurde
zerquetscht gleich nach dem Abzug der
Israelis drehen wir mehrere Tage vor Ort
viele Wasser und Stromleitungen wurden
beschädigt die sind das was man noch am
schnellsten reparieren kann
andere Schäden zeigen sich erst auf den
zweiten Blick und manches wird sich nie
reparieren lassen wir treffen Mohammed
Abo Diba sein 16-jähriger Sohn wurde bei
den Kämpfen getötet
hier gibt es märtüre und hier in diesem
Haus auch eigentlich gibt es in jedem
Haus Märtyrer oder Häftlinge
geht mit uns zur der Stelle wo sein Sohn
husam getötet wurde er war mit dem
Motorroller unterwegs nahm offenbar
einen bewaffneten Kämpfer und dessen
selbst gebastelte Bombe mit als sie auf
einen weiteren Kämpfer trafen schlug die
Rakete der israelischen Drohne ein
dieser Motorroller gehörte meinem Sohn
gott segne ihn meine Lieben so
wir werden standhaft hier bleiben was
die Israelis tun ist umsonst das ist
alles was von meinem Sohn geblieben ist
ich werde es bis zu meinem Tod
beschützen
der Vater kannte das Risiko die ältesten
Söhne sind Anhänger der Terrorgruppen
Hamas und islamischer Jihad einer inhaft
einer auf der Flucht konnte oder wollte
er husam nicht zurückhalten
[Musik]
natürlich haben wir geredet aber er
sagte meine Freunde sind Märtyrer und
ich will auch Märtyrer werden was soll
ich hier allein alle meine Freunde sind
tot ich konnte ihn nicht stoppen es war
in seinem Blut sein Leben war immer
voller Angst und Schrecken normale
Menschen schlafen beim zwitschern von
Vögeln wir schlafen beim Knall von
Kugeln
jetzt hängen sie ein Plakat mit seinem
Sohn auf und den anderen getöteten bald
wird langsam überall zu sehen sein in
Jeanine
eines von dutzenden solcher Bilder in
der Stadt Vorbilder für die Jugend von
Janine
es braucht nicht viel um die jungen
Männer für den bewaffneten Kampf zu
gewinnen Gewalt und Zerstörung bestimmen
ihr Leben so wie das von Mohammad alul
er ist 15 und lebt mit der Großfamilie
in einem Haus das haben die Israelis bei
den Kämpfen schwer beschädigt noch ist
er selbst kein aktiver Kämpfer aber sein
Lebensweg scheint vor bestimmt
die Gewalt der Israelis zerstört die
Psyche der jüngeren Menschen wenn du
jung bist 15 16 oder 20 Jahre alt dann
trägst du eine Waffe und bist beim
Widerstand
fließt in deinem Blut
die Israelis haben unsere Zukunft
zerstört
und doch träumte auch er mal von einem
anderen Leben als dem eines märterers
mein Traum war mal etwas zu lernen zu
reisen zu heiraten mir ein Leben
aufbauen diesen Traum hat die Armee
vernichtet
wo der Hass wächst kennt er bald keine
Grenzen mehr ein Sog der auch die 56.000
Einwohner von genina erfasst mitten im
Zentrum beobachten wir eine Szene die
befremdet junge Männer verteilen
Süßigkeiten sie feiern dass ein
palästinensischer Terrorist gerade bei
einem Anschlag einen Israeli getötet hat
die Männer gehören zur Genin Brigade
einem Sammelbecken der verschiedensten
Kampfgruppen
mit uns reden wollen sie nicht aber ein
paar Straßen weiter treffen wir den
19-Jährigen Kaiser
natürlich gehen unsere Leute nach Israel
sie üben Rache aber was heißt das die
töten uns und wir sollen still bleiben
wir üben Rache und das ist auch richtig
so wir bleiben nicht still wenn sie uns
töten und töten und töten
bei der Beerdigung der totenkämpfer
zeigt sich allerdings ein tiefer Riss in
der Front der Palästinenser die
Sicherheitskräfte der Autonomiebehörde
in Ramada haben nicht mitgekämpft gegen
die Israelis eine Delegation von dort
will nachträglich Solidarität zeigen
doch das kommt nicht gut an vor offenem
Gräbern
die Funktionäre werden niedergebrüllt
Kati B KTB ruft die Menge Brigade
Brigade und bara bara raus raus
es kommt zu einem Handgemenge Schüsse
fallen
ein Kampf kann gerade noch vermieden
werden die Kluft aber bleibt
wir sind in einer Phase der Befreiung
wir brauchen konkrete Solidarität bei
der Befreiung und keine Teilnahme an
Trauerfeiern wer nicht mit unserem Kampf
teilgenommen hat soll auch nicht mit uns
trauern
heute besuchte Palästinenser Präsident
Mahmut Abbas demonstrativ seit langem
hat seine autonomie-behörde die
Kontrolle über die Stadt verloren es ist
der Versuch die Macht zurückzugewinnen
doch mit einem Kranz auf dem Friedhof
ist das nicht getan zu tief sitzt der
Vorhof der Kollaboration der Junge
Mohammed spricht aus was die meisten
hier denken
die Autonomiebehörde hat den Menschen im
Westjordanland noch nie geholfen sie
stehen auf der Seite der Israelis
Terroranschläge verhindern die
Autonomiebehörde stärken die radikalen
Schwächen keines der erklärten Ziele hat
Israels Einmarsch erreicht selbst die
Toten bleiben lebendig
sie sind nicht gestorben sie sind
Märtyrer bei Gott sie sind am Leben und
nicht tot
noch viele werden Ihnen nachfolgen eine
verlorene Generation
[Musik]